thirty three thousand five hundred
deaths annually are attributed to the
air quality impact of wildfire thirty
three thousand five hundred deaths
annually seems like such an absurdly
high number you know wildfires in a bad
year will kill 100 people directly which
is you know a big you know tragic number
but it's nowhere near the scale of you
know 33 000 which which the air probably
impacts it's just less directed happens
later and so it's it's a little bit
harder for people to wrap their heads
around but that's really the real danger
of wildfire is this air quality that
we're seeing
um and it makes Wildfire also not a West
Coast Regional issue but truly a
national or or a global issue
all right guys bang bang I've got bill
here with me uh the reason why we're
talking is because I put out a tweet and
I said who are the best young investors
that I should be talking to Paul Graham
responded and he said you being one of
them and so as I go ahead and I take a
look at what you guys are doing you are
using Venture Capital to help fight
wildfires or forest fires now maybe we
should just start with like what's the
difference between a wildfire and a
forest fire and then why do you care so
much about this problem
yeah totally so you know thanks again
for having me on I'm super excited to
talk about this you know I think
ultimately wildfire and forest fire is
the same thing but I think the reason
that people are increasingly using the
word Wildfire to talk about these these
phenomenon is that it refers to sort of
uncontrolled explosive wild fire
um you know fires have always burned in
the forests for thousands of years uh in
a very natural controlled State uh and
it's really a recent phenomenon of those
fires have got become become sort of
wild wildfires uh and so that's sort of
the the name is referring to you know
out of control fires in the in the
Wildland all right now you've got a very
personal story with this
um you uh were kind of living out in the
woods right or kind of in a more rural
area and you were actually seeing these
fires happen they were coming up along
the property line you were having some
of the health uh you know kind of impact
to you family friends Etc talk a little
bit about that experience and like what
what spoke to you so much to go and
spend you know a considerable amount of
your time energy on actually trying to
solve the problem
yes I was a fintech entrepreneur I
started and sold a company called we pay
to JPMorgan
um and then I was spending some time at
JP Morgan as part of that acquisition
and you know as part of that spending a
lot of time in rural Northern California
in a town called Booneville in the
Anderson Valley
um and certainly over the last five
years we've seen an explosion in fire
particularly in Northern California we
saw the campfire the tubs fire and a
number of other just sort of large large
incidents and those you know we had
Direct impacts you know a fire called
the peach fire burned on the access road
to our property uh and then the indirect
impacts of smoke and and all that that
sort of comes with it uh it just kind of
got to this point where I was just
seeing it so constantly and I was like
there's got to be something that we can
do about this problem and
um you know as I left JP Morgan
um wanted to work on something new
wanted to sort of dive into a new topic
and I was just like this is right in my
backyard it seems important it also
seems like technology can play a role in
helping solve it and so it just kind of
piqued my interest to uh to learn more
so my understanding of these wildfires
is as you mentioned mentioned they have
happened for ever essentially and
there's actually a natural explanation
and an importance to having the fire
there's a clearing out of brush and and
kind of this like natural process
explain maybe like the positives and
like why we actually need some fire but
then what happens when we cross over
into these negative impacts is it just
that like humans have moved far enough
into the woods that all of a sudden now
they're endangering themselves or is
there something else going on that takes
it from like that Natural Evolution of
you know fire and nature to now uh we
actually have to solve the problem or
stop these fires from spreading yeah
it's especially people moving into
Harm's Way but the much bigger issue is
as you said for thousands and thousands
of years like fires burned in the
landscape and they burned very
frequently but they because they burned
so frequently they burned at low
severity so maybe every five six seven
years you'd have a low severity Wildfire
come through it would burn you know
ground cover and brush it would leave
the mature trees it would leave the
forest in this very resilient State and
those those fires would start because of
lightning but also because indigenous
people would actually like them to help
manage the land and create you know
Pathways and clear brush and stuff like
that
um and then a hundred years ago we you
know a little more 100 years ago we we
went and colonized the you know west
coast of the United States and
um we started putting out these fires at
much greater rates you know we
um we had Timber and Agriculture and
grazing and we had these assets to
protect and so we created you know these
uh forestry departments that would
actually go and suppress these fires and
that actually worked fairly well for for
50 or hundred years you know we were
able to control these fires but it was
kind of this spring that we've just been
loading over the past Century where
we've just been suppressing so much
stuff stuff's not burning now you've got
just tremendous fuel density uh out in
the forest and so you know you take that
you know huge fuel density some people
estimate it's about four or five times
denser than it was a hundred years ago
you layer on climate change uh where you
know now the fire seasons are longer and
hotter you go put a bunch of houses
right in the middle of it and then you
string hundreds of thousands of miles of
power lines through it all uh and that's
kind of the recipe for disaster that
we've created but it's largely
self-inflicted
um I think the good news is that we can
we can undo a lot of that and and I
think it is a solvable problem but
that's sort of the situation we're in
before we get into some of the
technology that you think can solve the
problem and some of the numbers behind
this talk a little bit as to kind of the
human interaction with the forest or or
with these fires so uh on the East Coast
something that people would be familiar
with is like flood zones right when you
buy a house they tell you hey you're you
had a higher susceptibility to a flood
and so Insurance changes people may not
buy the home homes could be built on
stilts like there's all these things
that happen around floods is the same
thing happening now on the west coast
around these fires where people are
getting zoned uh and so they know that
there's a higher susceptibility is there
insurance premium changes are there
homes that are being built in a
different way they just talk about maybe
some of the the things that are
happening now that this is becoming a
more frequent uh occurrence yeah we're
just starting to figure a lot of that
out you know floods I think have been a
pretty well understood phenomenon for a
long time but you know extreme Wildfire
is actually a fairly recent phenomenon
it's eight of the ten most destructive
wildfires in U.S history have happened
since 2017. so it's like wow you know
it's really become only in the last say
five to ten years it's reached this this
Tipping Point and you're right it's
driving all those types of changes that
we've seen with other types of national
disasters but we're still kind of at the
very early days you know we saw in
California in the last couple weeks you
know uh Allstate stopped writing new
homeowners policies State Farm has as
well and so you have these insurers that
aren't really sure what to do they're
kind of ill-equipped to understand the
real risks to these homes all they know
is it's going exponential and so they're
trying to kind of step back until they
can figure it out I think that's the
opportunity for for entrepreneurs and
and for uh you know Founders in
particularly to step in and say okay
there's Solutions we can build to these
problems right we can manage vegetation
around homes we can build homes of
different materials we can you know
cover gutters cover uh Ember events or
recover events protective members so
there's things we can do but I think a
lot of the housing stock has not been
built um with that in mind and that's
sort of where we are today so let's talk
how these fires get started
um if people just read headlines they
always remember the one that like got
started by the idiot who like set off a
firework or you know did it being
malicious or nefarious is that the
majority or are these natural
occurrences where maybe lightning
strikes or like just talk you know kind
of what what is the way the fires are
started and then is there a probability
or like a distribution in terms of human
driven versus nature driven sure yeah so
so lightning definitely causes uh some
fire it's on the order of magnitude of
maybe 15 or 20 percent of wildfires
started by lightning
um I think you know the vast majority is
caused by humans in various ways it's
you know the campfire that you know
someone didn't watch enough Smokey the
Bear ads and so they left left the
campfire burning it's the gender reveal
party it's stuff like that but one of
the really big and important causes is
that utilities cause a huge amount of
wildfire it's about 11 of ignitions get
caused by utilities but it's actually
about 50 of the damage gets caused by
utilities
um because it's those same high winds
that cause a tree to fall on those power
lines are the same high winds that cause
that Wildfire to go from a small fire
that could be contained quickly to you
know a huge Inferno
um you know in sort of record time so
you know humans definitely cause it it's
definitely sort of carelessness on the
on the part of of people that cause a
chunk of them but really utilities cause
the majority of the really extreme
wildfires and that's
um and I think that's a really important
thing to know because it's a it's a
solvable problem by these utilities or
at least you know it can be mitigated in
in pretty large ways so we have a fire
that gets started it starts spreading
obviously wind and other things can
really kind of accelerate these uh if
anyone's seen the movie Only the brave I
think it was the Granite Mountain
HotShots is uh the group there I had to
look that up to remember it but uh they
look awesome right like they're like you
know going into the fire they're digging
the trenches they're trying to fight
these things control them talk a little
bit about uh maybe their reaction that
people have today and kind of how we're
treating it before we get to things that
you all are trying to do you know in
kind of a preventative way but like what
is the hot shots and kind of this forest
fire fighting you know forces that we
have uh that we deploy whenever these
things kick up yeah we have an
incredible heroic Workforce that you
know we have us forest service we have
state agencies like Cal Fire in
California we have local fire department
and like for 99.9 of the wildfires like
that apparatus works really flawlessly
you know 9-1-1 call goes in they
Dispatch they can contain stuff quickly
and early
um and and I think that really does work
and it's worked really well for a long
period of time I think the challenge is
that we're just seeing this like crazy
new fire Behavior that's never been seen
before and you can get these starts in
the wrong conditions where it's 70 mile
an hour winds outside it's incredibly
dry it's the feeling of a giant hair
dryer everywhere and you start a fire in
those conditions there's almost nothing
you can do to stop it like it's just it
grows so quickly and exponentially that
even if you had the cruise really close
and and unseen and you know could get
there immediately just really really
difficult to contain fire and those um
those conditions and so I think that's
what sort of leads you to say Okay
suppression alone cannot be the solution
we have to actually think about how do
you mitigate how do you do things to
mitigate fire damage and fire intensity
long before they start to give those
suppression resources a chance in those
extreme conditions let's talk some
numbers real quick so you guys came out
when you announced that you were going
to do this you had about a 35 million
dollar fund I'm assuming that you guys
have aspirations to raise future funds
and kind of continue to grow the capital
base that you can go and deploy into
this there's about five billion dollars
in the latest infrastructure bill that
is specifically devoted to these uh
issues and and kind of complex
challenges but the U.S forest Service
I've seen you say estimate that there's
about 50 billion dollars that's going to
be needed to actually handle this stuff
how big is kind of the addressable
Market when you look at it as a venture
capitalist and you say okay we're gonna
go deploy Capital into this are we
talking about there can be 100 million
dollar outcomes billion dollar
multi-billion dollar outcomes how many
of these companies do you think are
going to be built like just talk a
little numbers and kind of what the
opportunity set is as an investor yeah I
believe there's going to be over a dozen
uh unicorn companies built in firetech I
think it's that big of a problem and and
that big of an opportunity and you're
right there's a there's record federal
spending on Wildfire you know we've got
money in the infrastructure bill
um money in the ira uh the agencies are
really doing land treatment and
suppression and investing in technology
at you know sort of record levels
um given the the depth of the challenge
and I think that's as we've talked about
only the beginning of what's actually
needed but you know for entrepreneurs
you know government dollars and public
dollars is one potential Market but
there's really big opportunities in
helping utilities adapt insurance
companies adapt Timber companies adapt
real estate companies adapt
um these are you know huge huge
Industries some of the largest
Industries on the planet that are being
turned upside down by wildfire in some
really important regions you know you
think about PG e who's the
um the major utility in Northern
California they lost 80 billion dollars
of market capitalization after the
campfire they went bankrupt they gotta
find 25 billion dollars the CEO lost
their job you know that is not a small
thing you know that is not a small
disruption operations it literally
turned the company inside out and so now
they spend you know seven or eight
billion dollars a year on Wildfire
mitigation across the board that's one
utility uh and you can bet all the other
utilities are watching that kind of
stuff and don't want that to happen to
them and so you know the utility sector
in particular spends a huge amount of
money on Wildfire mitigation which is
you know maybe tripled over the last
couple years insurance industry is
losing between 10 and 15 billion dollars
a year in the US again huge dollars at
stake
um you think about like the real estate
Industries they take hotels uh in some
of the more recent Napa fires some
really large Resorts burn to the ground
air quality affects travel and occupancy
you know again these are like really big
dollar amounts affecting really big
businesses and there's a real
willingness for these businesses to
spend on on Solutions so you know we you
know if you take all that together you
know we estimate that spending in the
U.S is about 50 billion dollars a year
on Wildfire mitigation across all these
different sectors I think it's a really
attractive market and it's growing
quickly and there's an even bigger one
internationally too let's talk about
some of the companies that you guys have
already invested in one of the big
categories I think is what I'll call
kind of detection or camera and
satellite type Imaging maybe you can
describe one or two of the businesses
that you guys have uh funded there and
like the importance of uh it seems at
least from my perspective of identifying
you know where could fires be occurring
uh like what are like the the
preconditions if you will and kind of
higher likelihood areas but then also
like hey is there a fire or is there not
a fire it sounds it sounds like you've
got a couple of companies that are doing
that as well yeah so um one of the
companies we've invested is called Piano
Ai and so piano
puts uh cameras on tops of mountains and
cell phone towers uh and uses AI to
analyze the video uh so that you can
quickly detect a fire start uh you know
you think of fire again growing
exponentially you can catch it in that
first five or ten minutes your chances
of being able to intervene before it
gets really big go way up uh and in
addition you also get situational
awareness to know like hey what's the
rate of spread where's it going you can
tailor your dispatch uh whereas maybe
previously all you'd have is a 911 call
if someone says hey there's smoke behind
my house you got to send an engine it
takes 15 or 20 minutes for them to find
it before they can sort of call out the
full dispatch you're short circuiting
the whole process so you can make a
smarter decision has a huge impact on
the ability of suppression and it's a
great application of of Technology their
big customers are landowners
um but with utilities as well that are
trying to sort of think about how do
they de-risk
um fire starts in in the regions where
um they're responsible so those cameras
are obviously as you said kind of near
the ground I've seen also that you guys
have looked at things from satellites
and kind of satellite imagery things uh
from that front what do you think is
possible from satellites that maybe the
cameras can't do or have you guys said
hey look maybe the satellites actually
can't help
yeah no I think detection will be solved
by a kind of a layered approach you know
cameras are really great at covering you
know 50 or 100 square miles and giving
you real-time situational awareness
which is which is awesome satellites can
cover much broader areas but have much
lower resolution in terms of
understanding what's actually happening
and you know much lower sort of
frequency or so much higher uh latency
uh in terms of seeing what's actually
happening so you know it's kind of a
layered approach you might use a
satellite to monitor really rural areas
like say the interior of Australia but
you might use cameras to monitor the
Wild and urban interface around a town
in northern California and so I think
it's kind of both
um working in concert that being said we
also are investors in a company called
overstory which uses satellite imagery
in a slightly different way they
actually help utilities understand
vegetation risks to their power lines so
they'll help you know someone like a PG
e uh say hey you've got a diseased
40-foot Douglas fir tree you know within
six feet of a power line that's a very
high risk tree you got to go take that
out and it brings the visibility to a
really big distribution Network and
helps them prioritize where they're
going to do tree trimming which is a
huge way they prevent Wildfire so we've
got uh kind of camera detection
satellite detection Etc uh once the
fires starts are there opportunities to
invest around how to actually treat the
fire how to cut the fires you know path
of movement off what what are some of
the things you guys are either invested
in or excited about in that area
yeah we've seen a bunch of different
um you know work happening there you
know ranging from
um you know new types of chemicals to uh
you know to put out fire in a safer more
environmentally friendly way to you know
all kinds of new types of Machinery
um to try to think about fire
suppression the thing that we're
probably most excited about in the
suppression category is
um drones or other types of technology
that can help with rapid initial attack
so you know again those first 5 10 15
minutes of a fire are so critical you
know if you can detect it and then you
can get [__] there quickly
um yeah you have a chance to catch it
before it gets out of control and some
of these really adverse conditions and
so we're investors in a company called
rain that builds autonomous drones to do
fire suppression
um with the idea being that you could
you get that fire start you can actually
have an aircraft in the air almost
immediately and on its way there to be
able to a give you a size up and
understand what's happening but B
actually start suppression operations
which again short circus that cycle as
other other resources are kind of making
their way on site yeah it makes it 10
cents um talk to me about the home uh
you mentioned earlier covers you
mentioned maybe building materials what
are you guys seeing there what are you
investing in what's exciting
yeah so we're um we're investors in a
couple things in that in that space
um one is a company called uh delos uh
and so delos is building a new type of
homeowners insurance so trying to
basically you know these insurers are
struggling to price Wildfire risks delos
has a bunch of really bright uh you know
mlnai scientists that are
um a better understanding the Dynamics
of fire better modeling it and are able
to price risk more intelligently which
means they can ensure more homes than
insurers might otherwise be able to
um we're also taking you know a couple
hard look at look at some other
companies in that in that space that
actually analyzing the home itself and
saying you know hey this is what's uh
this is what's attractive about this
home in terms of its Wildfire
defensibility here's what's unattractive
and helping trying to quantify some of
that risk and ideally help the homeowner
make those changes
um and we're investors in a company that
is called fire maps that sort of help to
analyze those homes and um actually
helps the homeowners say okay I'm gonna
make these improvements or changes put a
new roof on my house or put a gutter
guard to protect against member
intrusion which is actually helping
mitigate the risk of the home
and when you see other categories is
there anything else that sticks out to
you is like hey these are the really
really big opportunities this is where
we can go put money to work pre-seed
seed and we think that it can grow and
compound for a number of years
yeah so I think the other so if you
think about Wildfire as a problem I
think suppression is one one solution
um you know sort of asset protection or
Community hardening is another solution
so protecting homes I think the third
category is really around landscape
resilience so this is like how do we
take these really big forests and return
them to a state of resilience back to
that Natural State and so we invested in
a company called burnbot that
um has actually built like a large
robotic tractor device that has you know
basically blow torches underneath of it
and a big fan and that can basically
crawl through different terrain and
conduct what's called prescribed burning
so you're actually going to burn fuel
underneath that device but you're doing
in a really contained way that's safe
you know you're pulling a bunch of a
bunch of oxygen through so you get
really efficient combustion which a
makes it faster but B reduces the Smoke
by a lot so you can now do you know kind
of fuel treatment in areas that you
might not otherwise do or or in times of
the year when you might not otherwise be
able to do it safely this is a device
that sort of is making treatment more
scalable that's a huge part of the
solution is actually returning good fire
to the landscape
in ways that it happened historically
that's the only way we're going to get
this back in equilibrium now many people
will be thinking about air quality right
now as we talk about wildfires forest
fires because in New York City uh for
like the first time in forever there was
this horrible air quality it was you
know kind of orange looking all the
pictures went viral online it didn't
come from New York it obviously came
from uh the fires up in Canada but you
had a statistic when you guys announced
your Venture Capital firm that just blew
me away that three thirty three thousand
five hundred deaths annually are
attributed to the air quality impact of
wildfire 33 500 deaths annually seems
like such an absurdly high number for
air quality specifically related to
wildfires so talk about uh kind of what
you all are seeing west coast East Coast
obviously the thing in New York and then
are there potential Solutions there that
you all think are investment
opportunities
um that can not only save lives but also
return capital
yeah it's a pretty stunning statistic
isn't it someone took you know basically
air quality uh air quality data and then
looked at mortality rates and and sort
of correlated the two and determined
that that air quality from Wildfire is
sort of contributing to death at this
huge scale you know wildfires in a bad
year will kill 100 people directly which
is you know a big Tre you know tragic
number but it's nowhere near the scale
of you know 33 000 which which the air
quality impacts it's just less directed
happens later and so it's it's a little
bit harder for people to wrap their
heads around but that's really the real
danger of wildfires this air quality
that we're seeing
um and it makes Wildfire also not a West
Coast Regional issue but truly a
national or or a global issue
um as we've seen and so you know I think
there's opportunity though for companies
to to help with that you know uh you
know you can think about air filtration
in homes you know how do we uh we
certainly Geo during covet everyone had
their sort of local little air filter
but is that really the best we can do is
that the um is that the the end all
Beyond or their whole home filtration
systems you know is there a future where
you know built into your furnace or
under your air conditioning you've got
you know real filtration for smoke
because you're going to need that uh
from air quality the forecast for air
quality are also quite depressing you
know we I looked at a study from NASA
that was saying that in you know by sort
of 2060 2070 the average air quality in
the Bay Area will be equivalent to like
our really terrible summer of 2020 when
we had that orange Sky day in San
Francisco and that'll just be an average
year and so I think if we don't get the
fire problem under control
um we're gonna have to deal with this
air quality issue and it's going to
become a global Public Health crisis uh
so you know I think there's opportunity
for technology to help in terms of
forecasting in terms of filtration
um but uh but it's a pretty significant
problem that needs to be uh taken
seriously another thing that you called
out was uh the impact on market value
and again these numbers just kind of
blew my mind you said the 2018 campfire
resulted in 25b billion dollars in
liability for PG e a guilty plea for
homicide and it erased over 80 billion
dollars in market capitalization
25 billion liability uh 80 billion
dollar market cap Wipeout and then a
guilty homicide plea I don't think
people who haven't spent the time to
look at this stuff really understand
just how big those numbers are what the
impact is ETC describe a little bit more
about that situation and kind of what
the what what led to these you know kind
of massive numbers to be impacted yeah
so the campfire in Paradise was a just a
toll an absolute tragedy you know it
started on a uh you know based on a
faulty piece of equipment on a
transmission line quickly within the
span of a few hours you know burned down
a paradise uh and
um you know just uh you know kill a
bunch of people and destroyed the entire
town it was I mean it's just truly I
think a horrific tragedy there's some
documentaries that have been done on it
and I think if folks are interested or
want a visceral sense of what this stuff
is like uh it's worth worth watching you
know ultimately it was traced to a
faulty hook on a transmission tower
that hook uh had been you know hadn't
been replaced in nearly a hundred years
uh and so it sort of slowly wore down
and eventually caused the you know in
these this high wind condition it was I
think it was about 70 mile an hour winds
the hook failed wire fell hit the tower
sent the shower Sparks uh and then those
same 70 mile an hour winds just carried
those Flames quickly through the through
the town
um you know PG e the utility is liable
is liable for that uh and you know and
that's
um you know particularly when you think
about the negligence involved in the
maintenance now since then they've
dramatically changed their approach to
this they're you know upgrading
infrastructure left and right
um and and definitely do not want to do
this again and our uh you know investing
infrastructure at sort of record levels
um but you know the the reality remains
if 200 000 miles of power lines in
Northern California you can't upgrade
that overnight uh and even if you do
there's certain conditions where you
know fires are still going to start and
so I I think it's a real really serious
thing for utilities it's really the only
one of the only reasons a utility CEO
can lose their job in the span of a
weekend is you know they can go home on
Friday and come back on Sunday and and
be out of a job if uh if they start a
wildfire so it's not just PG e that has
this this liability it's it's utilities
you know across lots of wildfire exposed
areas which is a big percentage of the
country and world
who's starting some of these startups
are these like you know Wildfire
firefighters who are like hey I'm really
familiar with the problem or these
people who live in these communities are
these Tech entrepreneurs who are like
how do I get as far away from uh you
know cubicle in office as possible and
let me get out into nature like who who
are you running into as you're kind of
evaluating these companies and seeing uh
you know who really the founders are
yeah it's a mixture of all those things
I don't think it's like a homogeneous
Community you know it's we've got you
know the CEO of Pano Sonia was a product
manager at Google you know on nest and
really you know spend a bunch of time
doing Hardware design for cameras and
then said hey I want to apply this
technology that I know a lot about
um to a problem that's a little bit more
meaningful than tracking the Amazon
package showing up on someone's driveway
and uh you know you thought about that
hey you know computer vision could be
used to detect wildfire and help protect
people uh and I think it was sort of the
mission that Drew her into this uh this
category you know the CEO of overstory
uh which is the the satellite-based
vegetation management solution for
utilities he's a really accomplished
data scientist
um that was working on climate analytics
and realized that one of the highest
leveraged problems in climate is
Wildfire prevention and so
um you know kind of went deep on
wildfire and thought about how you could
apply his skill set there too so you
know it's a it's an next and you know
certainly across all these teams we've
got firefighters and Foresters and you
know various types of practitioners that
um you know kind of Bring The Real World
Experience uh and can kind of combine it
with the technology and so I think that
mixture is uh is really the secret sauce
what are you seeing in terms of
valuations and you mentioned earlier a
dozen one billion dollar plus companies
you think can come out of this sector so
what does that really look for uh like
in terms of how much Capital they'll
need to get there right some businesses
especially that are outside of just pure
software uh they're incredibly Capital
intensive some businesses are incredibly
Capital light what are you kind of
anticipating here as you guys really
kind of pioneer investing in this
specific sector
yeah I think it's a mix you know we're
we're sector focused but we're kind of
Technology agnostic so we have some
companies like rain or burnbot that are
building you know real serious Hardware
you know I would say heavy machinery
um flying heavy machinery which
obviously is very Capital intensive uh
and then we've got software companies
that help you know uh uh fire
departments do Home Inspections and some
of those companies are profitable so you
know it's uh I think there's kind of a
mix it depends a little bit on their
approach I think one of the things about
being pretty like vertically focused
though is that a lot of our companies
are just really close to their customer
they've got significant Revenue you know
these are not like we're gonna go build
a social network and sell ads later kind
of businesses they are we're going to
co-create with our customer we're going
to get paid along the way
um and sort of grow you know grow
alongside them so
um you know it's kind of a mix I don't
think there's really any one uh one type
of company that we're funding and then
when you look at uh kind of co-investors
one of the things that at the pre-seed
and Seed uh level is always in
interesting to me is like you need other
people to come along right usually
you're not going to take down an entire
round and then obviously you need people
to follow on in series a series B series
C who are you seeing participating these
deals are these just generalist Venture
capitalists are there other kind of I
guess fire funds that are out there uh
what what are you seeing you know in
some of the round constructions
I haven't met anyone else crazy enough
to start a fire fund just yet but you
know maybe one day I think maybe my job
will be done when that when that happens
uh but there are a lot of other firms
that are investing in in Wildfire as a
market
um you know there's certainly climate
firms that you know see Wildfire as a
subset of climate and happy to talk
about that relationship it's pretty
interesting
um but there's also just generalist VC
firms that's want to invest in software
uh or or AI or data companies
um and see the opportunity in in this
market uh as well so part of my job is
to be a bit of an evangelist to try to
invite those folks in and and to see the
opportunity here and help co-invest
inside alongside our companies uh you
mentioned the relationship between
wildfire and climate describe that
yeah so wildfires cost five percent of
global CO2 emissions it's huge it's
bigger than the country of Russia uh so
you know you could as you think about
trying to solve climate change and
reduce carbon dioxide emissions you know
you can put a heat pump in hundreds of
millions of people's homes or you can
totally re-engineer the transportation
sector or we can find ways to intervene
in wildfire and to create resilient
Landscapes
um and dramatically reduce the emissions
caused by wildfire and we can do it in a
relatively short period of time so I
think it's actually in terms of like
dollars in and time required I think one
of the easiest ways to reduce carbon
emissions in the short term
um you know is to try to solve this
Wildfire problem and we can really make
a dent in global emissions if we do so
because it is this negative feedback
loop you know wildfires cause carbon
emissions which causes warming which
then causes more wildfires and that's
kind of a bad Loop to be in but the good
news is we can interrupt it and if we do
so I think it'll be one of the largest
shortest term levers on reducing uh
carbon emissions my last question for
you is about your team team uh I noticed
that you have a whole collection of
people with very unique backgrounds
um what's the pitch to get them to come
work for you how do you figure out who's
got the skills and the experience versus
just who's enthusiastic about this you
know what are you looking for in some of
those team members yeah totally so I
think the thing that attracts people to
this Market in general and hopefully the
convective as well is that you know
we're working on a really important
problem in Mission like if we can put
better tools in the hands of
practitioners
um you know we can save people's lives
we can you know help save our
environment and we can have a massive
impact on on the climate crisis uh so I
think that mission helps attract people
you know our team is myself I've got
three part-time Partners who are all
former founders of of uh really
successful uh technology companies one
is George Whitesides who is the CEO of
Virgin Galactic one's Elia volodarski
who co-founded segment uh and then one
is Annika Latinos who uh sold a company
called guavas uh to the Tails group uh
and then we were joined by our director
of operations Aaron wood who is my
assistant that we pay for 10 years so
you know the five of us have kind of
built companies before and we've been we
know what that means and we're really
attracted to the mission here I think
that's a really good combination you
know we we think we can be helpful
advisors to you know Founders as they're
as they're building their companies
um and we all just kind of get it we
know we know what the process is like uh
and you know we get excited about
building companies having big impact
makes uh makes complete sense to me
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or if they've got a company
that they think uh potentially could be
interesting to you guys send it to you
yeah I'm just on Twitter at bill clerico
or you can send me an email Bill
collectivecapital.com
um always happy to chat with folks
working in the space all right and now
my last question you've been investing
for a while now what is the one thing
that has surprised you the most before
you started investing that you know now
that would have been helpful to know
back then
yeah I think think um one of the
mistakes that operators make when they
turn to investors is they get excited
about the idea and they think about how
they could go execute that idea and I
think what I've realized now as an
investor is it's actually much more
about the founder and the person you
know the idea is part of it and it's
easy to get excited about the idea but
you have to get excited about the person
and if and they're the ones that are
actually going to do that work and
that's you know so much more of our
underwriting now around Investments
revolves around the founders versus the
the idea itself that is a great piece of
advice bill I appreciate this I learned
a ton today uh I never thought that I
would be talking in such great detail
about wildfires but I feel better
informed now when I see it in the news
and obviously you guys are doing
fantastic work not you know and I think
what's so inspiring about it is not just
that you're trying to solve kind of the
hard technical problem with the fire
itself but the ramifications of saving
lives saving property Etc is uh is quite
uh commendable so I appreciate
everything you guys are doing and we'll
definitely do this again in the future
thanks for having me on